[Music]
i always had a grind so i just saw
opportunities as they came up to further
myself and i took every opportunity that
i could get
[Music]
my name is cole mason i'm the ceo of
pear pop i'm 25 years old
i've always had an entrepreneurial
spirit since i was little from selling
handmade crosses door to door to
being a failed youtuber trying to grow
myself through that didn't work out i
got like 10 views of video but then
post that i then got signed by ford
model so i moved out and going to
castings the first thing that they would
ask for is followers next to your name
so through that i had to go through the
social media grind again and go through
everything to figure out how to grow
myself
after that i started promoting in
nightlife so with promoting i was able
to meet so many influencers and i
realized that there was a huge
discrepancy in pay for creators it was
so crazy to me to think like some of
these guys were pulling in more views
than a tv show
but they weren't getting paid for it so
what i wanted to do was create powerpuff
just through basically my experiences
and what i had gone through on growing
myself
[Music]
hair pop the the mission of it is we're
moving from platform driven awareness to
people driven influence
we were able to get now 85 000 creators
where now the creators aren't gonna have
to go
and post for free anymore right now they
have to go on log in and say pick a
sound pick a creative to use so why go
do that and let the platform make the
money when you can go with us and then
get paid for your views on across all
social platforms
[Music]
persistence is everything when you're
first starting it feels i guess like the
whole world is against you right you go
up against every problem you could
imagine but persistence is key if the
drive is there you'll see the
opportunities in everything and you just
take those opportunities as they come
and eventually things pan out
you